Lisa, what post election hobby are you starting to cultivate? Because,
you know, things feel out of control.
We need something to control in our tiny little lives.
So glad you asked. It is book acquisition.
Now, this was already a hobby of mine because I'm a home school mom,
so we have a little home library,
but I wanted to expand that, um,
just because, A,
I'm a homeschool mom, so you can never have enough books,
never have enough knowledge.
Knowledge is power. Knowledge is everything, right?
And they can't get rid of all the books,
and in a home school, they can't ban the books.
So I just went to my local habitat for Humanity Restore.
By the way, if you were in Charleston,
the Mount Pleasant one is fabulous.
And I got what I would consider probably around 100 books,
maybe more, for about $60.
Now, I'm talking fiction,
non fiction, hobby, uh,
encyclopedia, thesaurus,
all sorts of different types of books.
And I'm gonna continue adding to our home library.
A, again,
because I'm a homeschool mom,
and B, because you cannot ban knowledge,
and I live in a southern state where they actively are banning books.
I am also focusing in on books,
of things of knowledge that I do not have yet.
Skill sets and hobbies that I have not acquired in my brain.
I would like to have references for.
So I've got. Let's see,
this one I'm really excited about.
Somebody put Some post its in these.
Can't wait to see what they posted it.
Big Book of Backyard Projects.
Fucking absolutely. Um,
everything for home brewing, because,
you know, prohibition doesn't usually stop at women's rights.
Um, very excited about these two.
And then, of course,
for the kids, Sarah Plain and tall,
an absolute classic. Is this gonna fix the state of the world?
Absolutely not.
But will I be the library for anybody who needs access to education
if we don't like where the school system's going?
Absolutely. Let's do rebel educator.
Was not on my bingo card for my life.
Was not. Was not at all. But here we are.